i think that people tend to think of
sociopaths more as men
and then which probably gives female
sociopaths the advantage and that people
are less likely to
um like the elizabeth holmes like people
who are really manipulative and really
good at it um
and and
part of
how they're able to succeed is that
people don't understand their motives or
people will assume that people behave
rationally even if rationally means
it's like anthony strange's
you know it would have made more sense
if he had gotten all this money out of
me
and you know put it in an overseas
account and then ditched me and got on a
plane to mexico like everybody would
understand that more
whereas
you know the way
things happened and he dragged me around
the country and like what were we doing
in tennessee and then
why didn't like nothing really makes any
sense
but
and also all the things that he did
to me and had me do it was as if
all of those things together only make
sense if his primary goal
was to maximally destroy me and also
make it
like have me burn all my bridges and
make it so i'll never recover
and when you read a book like that you
understand that that's
that's what he wanted like that's his
life
it's like a game like what what do you
think it's about power and it's a game
do you think he understood the long term
goals he has or was it the short term
game of it that he enjoyed the ability
to destroy you well yeah it was the
short-term
game of it because control another human
yeah and also i think for him like
their motivations are just different so
you know he spent a year incarcerated
because he never got out on bail but
then he got out
um
he's out of prison now he got out before
i went in to serve my time which was
um particularly
you know
like psychologically i had to try really
hard not to be infuriated and
um
but anyway
so i think for him
you know the consequence of spending
time in jail sort of like an
inconvenience
you know it's like life is a game
and so he wouldn't feel
if you're not capable of being
emotionally hurt
then you're
you know you have immense power because
you can go around and do things
and people can't hurt you it's like a
superpower and he did this for people
who are not familiar i guess he did this
to other women
yes
yes i think it was in the documentary
that
his i guess ex-wife
from somewhere else florida florida of
course florida
sorry
strong
strong words well it's just like when
there's the weirdest story about you
know people eating
tide pods and then doing crazy it's like
it's always in it's always in florida so
i feel like whenever crazy so to me it
makes sense that he would have spent
time in florida before and that's where
crazy in a good way
and i mean that on an insult on him i
also like she's an amazing person yes so
it's it's like it's him that i'm
making the like
florida is not that weird
yes he he manipulated her as well lied
to her that kind of things
you